Let us now consider an
application of what we have
done so far.
Let X be a normal random
variable with
given mean and variance.
This means that the PDF of X
takes the familiar form.
We consider random variable Y,
which is a linear function of
X. And to avoid trivialities,
we assume that a is
different than zero.
We will just use the
formula that we
have already developed.
So we have that the density of
Y is equal to 1 over the
absolute value of a.
And then we have the density of
X, but evaluated at x equal
to this expression.
So this expression will
go in the place
of x in this formula.
And we have y minus b over a
minus mu squared divided by 2
sigma squared.
And now we collect these
constant terms here.
And then in the exponent, we
multiply by a squared the
numerator and the denominator,
which gives us this form here.
We recognize that this is
again, a normal PDF.
It's a function of y.
We have a random variable
Y. This is
the mean of the normal.
And this is the variance
of that normal.
So the conclusion is that the
random variable Y is normal
with mean equal to
b plus a mu.
And with variance a squared,
sigma squared.
The fact that this is the mean
and this is the variance of Y
is not surprising.
This is how means and variances
behave when you form
linear functions.
The interesting part is that
the random variable Y is
actually normal.
Intuitively, what happened here
is that we started with a
normal bell shaped curve.
A bell shaped PDF for X. We
scale it vertically and
horizontally, and then shift
it horizontally by b.
As we do these operations, the
PDF still remains bell shaped.
And so the final PDF is again
a bell shaped normal PDF.